Freak bitches.
Sure.
I agree with you.
Can I switch gears?
Yeah.
I got to ask you about.
Ask me about anything.
Joey Diaz.
Tell me everything.
How did you meet Joe Ds?
Because I want you to ask me this.
I want you to ask me what my experience
with joy,
but how did you meet him?
How did he come into the fold?
I met Joey Diaz in the late nineties,
uh,
at the comedy store.
I think I met him in [inaudible] 96 or
97,
something like that.
Uh,
right when Joey moved to La.
We just started hanging around the
comedy store when we became friends and
then I started taking on the road with
me like,
uh,
the late nineties.
We've been best friends forever,
so I know of Joey.
I don't know Joey.
I've never met him.
Never met Joe.
Never.
I call him up right now.
TV and the whole bit.
And you know,
I know him from,
from you and I see your podcasts and all
that.
But.
And he's in the circles.
He does some Jujitsu.
He's funnier than hell and he's a
gangster.
So I liked him,
but I don't know anything about him.
So he comes on my podcast now he has a
podcast.
So of course my opening line to them is,
hey,
how'd you get into pocket?
Right?
I'm going to put here,
here's your plug for your podcast and
we're going to go on and talk about my
agenda.
So I say,
Joe,
I say to him,
Joey,
how'd you get into podcasting?
And his response,
you know Chael Sonnen,
he wouldn't call me jail.
It was always.
She still calls me Joe Rogan.
I'm mugged a hooker down in New Jersey
and senator Lee set her wig on fire.
It's okay.
We got to.
There's two moving parts here.
First off,
that is,
I don't know how that answers my
question of how,
but now I need to know the story here.
So we ties it all together with.
He went on something,
just something.
He got an appearance.
He told the story,
a mug and a hooker in New Jersey and
setting her wig on fire and all of a
sudden he blew up overnight and he goes,
yeah.
I realized people like the stores,
I never knew that I had stories from the
part of the country I'm in and the
neighborhood I grew up in,
I thought everybody had these doors.
He's like,
chill center,
and I thought I'd tell you I mogul
hooker and lighter wig on fire.
You Go,
yeah,
well I'm a 10 hookers and let 10 wigs on
fire.
I was like,
I didn't know I had stories and then it
just goes from there and he starts
telling me about sa Sa.
So he ends up doing two years or 18
months.
And I said,
well,
what kind of jam did you get in there?
And he said,
well,
I was actually,
I was doing the cop's job for them,
you know,
the cops don't want drugs on the
streets.
I went and took two kilos off the
streets for them.
This is how he presents it to me.
He goes,
yeah,
you know,
the,
the two kilos wasn't as big of a deal.
Oh.
He said,
Oh,
I,
I robbed two kilos.
He goes,
and you know what else?
Chael Sonnen.
I just happened to have a machine gun
and I go,
I can see where that happened because
she is sometimes you just back into a
machine gun.
I had a machine gun with me and he goes,
but it's funny.
I wasn't in trouble for the gun.
I really wasn't in that much trouble for
the drugs.
What they were upset about was the
kidnapping.
I'm going,
okay,
what?
What happened?
This is my intro to the guy.
I'm like,
what?
What in the hell is this story?
You probably know the story,
but I did it.
So he tells me the whole story and he
says,
yeah,
but you know,
kidnappings,
kind of a weird charge.
He goes,
when you invade Italy,
gotten that scuffle in the ultimate
fighter.
If I come and grab you and take you into
the next room just to cool you down,
taking into a room against your will,
that's kidnapping.
So I think like they got them on a
technicality jam,
like what they're doing with Frank Mir.
Some of these guys were talking about
and I said,
okay,
is that what happened?
And he goes,
no,
I duct taped the games in my trunk and
then I held him in the house for a week
before I let him go.
Well,
the why didn't you tell me?
Why did you bring up the initial example
of taking me next door and cooling me
debt?
What that have to do?
I still don't know because he's crazy.
Very kangaroo looking.
Yeah.
To kangaroos.
Scare the fuck out of me.
Now all the sudden they started getting
jacked.
You saw a lot of that when I was a kid
when I was a kid.
Do you think they lift?
Yeah,
they definitely.
They looked like they were fucking
school teachers.
Like they were newspaper reporters or
something,
or like a librarian.
They didn't look like these yoke
monsters.
You see the one that's knocking on the
window of the person's house like,
I want to come in.
Have you seen that video yet?
They wouldn't let a man knocking on the
door.
Come on.
Look how big that thing is.
That's one of their big.
Yeah,
look at that.
Like what?
What in the fuck is that?
That's fake.
I've seen it live,
so what the hell is going on?
Do you think they have that extra muscle
thing?
Like you said,
taking Dick Pills,
steroids and dick pills,
left fucking bizarre animal.
That is.
That is amazing.
Bouncy mammo that will kick you and try
to hurt you.
Fuck you up.
No,
no,
no.
They're not.
Always sit there and feed them.
I fit.
I felt the big pictures of me.
You to be really careful around the real
serious.
At a real post.
They say though,
they say though that if you find them in
the wild,
you are not supposed to ever while
beating off.
Is that kangaroo meat?
No,
no son.
We saw to having sex.
Oh,
the video though that it's kind of went
around last week is a kangaroo seeing
its reflection in somebody's window and
it's trying to fight it so.
But the guys on the other side with the
camera and it's just as jacked like
kangaroo,
like punching the window.
Like,
like it's scary.
Well yeah,
it's one of the coolest video that came
out last week.
If you just type in a kangaroo,
a window fist fighting himself in a
window,
shadowboxing a window.
That's a weird animal.
I love them.
I think they're great,
but it's so weird what it does.
Like the way it acts that sits on its
tail,
we.
It's bouncing around these legs and then
it's got those jacks.
Upper Body.
They were.
There was like a.
They get spooked.
Easy to like this one big one was trying
to have sex.
I'm going to say it wasn't sex.
It was definitely rape,
but it was like he was pulling her back
and she was trying to get away,
but there was a reason she was trying to
get away because there was like a weird
wind come that want to keen.
They all scattered.
Then they went under the tree and then
they got into it and I was like,
oh,
maybe she just wanted some privacy or.
That was really interesting how they had
to sneak out,
but she was scared and then as soon as
this weird thing came,
it was like a wind.
They all went scattered and then they
got back into.
It was exciting.
I liked Kanga.
Yeah,
this is.
It is scary.
I mean,
knock on the door.
That one's not too jacked.
Boy.
It's creepy though.
Oh my God.
Why?
It says,
and he starts getting pissed.
You scratched my window.
Small window.
This is the right video or maybe
the mirror.
Oh my God.
He's thrown himself at the window.
Fuck man.
He's trying to test themselves.
Oh.
He's trying to fight what he sees as a
reflection in the window.
Okay.
Whoa.